if you own a Tesla I'm going to share
with you exactly how you can charge it
100 free typically in Australia if you
own a Tesla and you're going to charge
it at home it's going to cost you about
50 cents a kilowatt at Peak time off
peak that's about 22 cents or 13 to
fully charge your car if you're game to
charge it super off peak between 9am and
3pm you can get it down to about five
dollars for a full charge or 8 cents per
kilowatt whereas if you're going out on
road trips like I do quite often you're
going to be paying 69 cents a kilowatt
which equates to about 40 dollars for a
full tank of electricity whereas if you
check out the plug share app or even
just keep an eye out in your local
community you're going to find a variety
of different destination charges which
all allow you to charge a Tesla 100 for
free anytime any day